[Música]
quem somos nós dentro dessa expansão
acelerada que tal ted hoje é a pergunta
que anda nos livros nos locais e nós
vamos mudar um pouco a visão vamos
inovar
nós vamos dizer quem aqui ou quem
colocou quem são os nossos programadores
quem nos permitiu pensar o que nós
pensamos hoje e nos construiu através da
instrução e foi com isso que nós
começamos uma jornada muitos anos atrás
e aos 19 anos
eu vou falar pra vocês sobrevida e soube
como conduzir a que nós chamamos de
movimento substância que é vida é
movimento em substância é o existir da
onde veio essas instruções porque se
educação como pedagoga nós sabemos que
ninguém pode educar ninguém porque ela
vem de dentro para fora
ela precisa ser despertada quem foi que
nos destruiu três programadores fortes
religião sociedade e família
se nós fomos hackear os nossos
comportamentos nós vamos encontrar esses
três grandes instrutores
então se nós olharmos para trás e
estudarmos um pouco e pesquisar os como
eles se comportam o que eles pensam
nós vamos observar da onde nós trouxemos
isso bom 28 anos de consultório de
psicoterapia atendendo jovens
adolescentes e casais mas 20 e poucos
anos vivenciando escolas e salas de aula
como professor naquela época de ensino
primário depois ensino médio
depois terceiro grau depois colt de
grandes empresários então 11 a época de
madre teresa de calcutá trabalhando com
a pobreza entendendo qual é o
significado e porque é que isso era tão
gratificante nas religiões que chegavam
a clamar depois estudos na área
tecnológica mas o mais importante
o encontro que aconteceu aos 19 anos de
idade e nós começamos então tivemos a
oportunidade de ouvir do tom e os
macrófagos isso fez uma virada de estilo
do estado de pensamento como ser
pensante que não nos adaptarmos aquilo
que era destruído e aceitar como uma
crente o magnética já em construção
ali nós encontramos um caminho de
laboratório de pesquisa como observar e
entender melhor a parte de neurociência
dentro de uma polivalência que nos era
mostrado de um universo tão abrangente
que resolvemos então olhar mais a fundo
seguidora não caberia porque uma cabeça
pensante não tem condições nem de que
ele quisesse seguir alguém alguma coisa
mais uma observador do universo e
sabedora de que nem tudo começou aqui e
que nós éramos uma galaxy somos tão
pequena tão tão distante de tantas
outras coisas não poderia ser só isso
que nos apresentava dentro da encontro
com os programadores nós fomos
observando como era construído dentro do
consultório
nós levávamos aqueles ensinamentos e
ficávamos observando como é que as
pessoas sofriam ela sofreu por causa dos
programas daquilo que elas acreditavam e
não conseguiam sair daquele aquário
daquela crença que havia sido imposta
muita vez numa criança dizendo você é
isso
nas escolas atendemos os filhos dado às
crianças que não aprendiam você é burro
você não tem condições e aquilo foi
martelando no encéfalo e isso fez com
que através desse trabalho
desenvolvemos junto adotou isso agrega o
chamado método mack grego que eu digo
que nós somos aqui pensei se porque o
nome é a quinta essência do método mack
grego onde se insere falo vai começar a
construir uma posição agnóstica
o revisionismo em tudo em tudo o que lhe
for observar o universo inclusivo
hipnose isso exclusivamente nele porque
não há nada de mudanças lá fora a
mudança acontece em nós
ampliar e expandir o nosso aquário de
ignorância que está todo dentro de duas
centenas chamado hemisfério esquerdo
hemisfério direito onde entrou dois
programas e nós precisamos para não
deixar que essa máquina também nos comba
command com essas instruções dadas
construir dentro de nós uma auto
programação onde tudo que nós possamos
estudar ler informar e gerar
conhecimento que é uma diferença nós
temos uma gama de informação e nós
gerarmos conhecimento dessas informações
e aí sim com sabedoria na ação a máquina
não poderá verdadeiramente está no
comando dessa máquina humana
então aí nós damos o nome dos e deltas
cibernéticos é aquele que tem lucidez
alto comando em todos os processos do
programa que ele permitiu que mantivesse
no seu e serve pra isso eu vou deixar
assim algo mais claro
nós consideramos que aqui e hoje a
ciência já está conseguindo evidenciar
essa posição na neurociência que aqui
nós temos um encéfalo mas o share ebro
que pensa ele está dentro de uma posição
cardíaco que nós chamaremos o cérebro do
coração
nós precisamos passar pelo sentir porque
as teorias podem ser adaptadas às
informações podem ser aceitas
crente porque veio de uma em um bamba da
informação mas ela é assim
ela funciona então nós precisamos ser
polivalentes independente da instrução
das faculdades mentais das chamadas
universidades que nós praticamos nós
vamos ter autodidatismo porque nos anos
ea lei muito além daquele conhecimento
que nos informaram que nos instruíram
mas
nos ensinaram a fazer um laboratório de
pesquisa como diria einstein onde estava
o laboratório e tirou a caneta debaixo
do papel que estava dentro do chapéu da
boina que ele utilizava o lápis aqui é
as observações é a minha vivência minha
sofrer em ciência são as minhas relações
então eu posso ter uma família diferente
eu posso ter um novo padrão nas
sociedades em curitiba com isso ter que
transformar os outros mas eu cada um no
seu espaço utilizando o tempo para a sua
construção construir sim um ser que está
além de uma mulher e de um homem e por
si só de uma competição e se nós formos
ver
nós viemos de ser uma flor de tista
dessa androgenia e nós continuamos
geneticamente andrógenos a nossa
manifestação a nossa matéria foi
separando ao longo dessa evolução
daquela criacionista ou do design
inteligente mas não importa
nós somos com diria ter achar dan seres
viajantes desse universo existindo uma
matéria por um tempo espaço e o que nós
estamos fazendo com esse tempo espaço
nós estamos utilizando para poder e cada
vez tem mais poder
nós estamos utilizando para ser e só ses
se nós fomos pra índia lá todo mundo
solo ser de nós fomos procedente está
todos no poder da competição a onde está
o cerne dessa situação que vai dizer é
um ser trabalhando numa máquina uma
espécie humana
o tempo das raças estão terminando e as
gerações que estão surgindo e os
rastreadores estão lá cantuta toda uma
tecnologia e esquecendo de se hackear
para poder enxergar melhor o uso a
utilização dessa tecnologia como nós
vamos utilizar essa tecnologia com
cibernética consciência daquilo que se
está trabalhando
se nós ou isso observa
achamos que a moral ela prende
determinadas atitudes de uma
comportamento de uma espécie mas é a
ética que trabalha e essa não está nem
nas religiões
nem na sociedade está se perdendo na
família está se construindo hoje uma
outra estrutura se certa ou errada essa
geração está trazendo se a tecnologia
está aí nós vamos ter criatividade
porque não basta nós por asas nas
lagartos
mas como diria mary ferguson nós
precisamos reconstruir e para isso nós
fizemos nos reconstruir como espécie da
onde veio nós no ocidente a esposa
eliana dá alívio total do nosso
pensamento
ele veio dizendo onde estava o certo eo
errado e aonde está o certo e errado
nós não matamos porque vamos pro inverno
nós não matamos porque a nossa lei é
ética não permite que nós avance a não
ser por defesa porque isso a espécie
humana como extinto tem como nós vamos
usar o nosso amor que é o que a espécie
humana não tem ele a não ser como humor
porque esse amor e compreensão como pode
eu deixar de amar é porque eu não tenho
compreensão daquilo que está à minha
frente eu ignoro aquela posição aquele
comportamento diferente que pensa
diferente que ver que enxergue que vive
de uma forma diferente que acredita
naquela sua forma e com isso tem toda
uma construção feita e só a pessoa pode
refazer essa construção
porque se ela for feita como maturana
diria uma aula construção é alguém de
fora que está mudando ela
e essa mudança ela precisa ser alto é da
observação do próprio observador e isso
foi trazido então um trabalho que tem
uma continuidade chamado método mark
grego através de aforismo que faz o caos
você está estabilizado encontrou a
felicidade então vamos gerar o caos
novamente porque aqui não é pra nós
encontrarmos a felicidade a forma que
nós fomos construído foi imposto essa
posição
o americana de felicidade é desafio
constante mutação constante relações
diferentes é coisas que acontecem e eu
aqui agora hoje hoje equivale e ontem
revisamos o que ontem fez com que eu
chegasse hoje dessa forma possa ser
amanhã é diferente então eu preciso
revisar aí entra uma posição
revisionista porque as coisas estão
acontecendo comigo e elas não podem
acontecer diferente foi um deus foi algo
de fórum circunstancial
o que está fazendo que eu não consiga
concretizar quer dizer eu pensei 'não
consigo agir e as coisas não saem do meu
comando
porque nas interações aonde estou
perdendo meu a minha força de realização
de concretização
então nós precisamos sentar nos revermos
porque nada
todas as pessoas tudo que nos acontecem
podem ser obstáculos mas não podem
impedir que nós passamos
e isso eu falo por experiência não foram
poucos os desafios que estamos hoje aqui
com vocês são mais de 50 anos numa
jornada trabalhando acima de tudo em nós
mesmos e todos os dias encontrando
coisas incríveis para aperfeiçoar em nós
e repartindo e conciliando e convivendo
com pessoas de universos tão diferentes
então nós vamos entender uma das coisas
mais belas se amor e compreensão e não é
um humor extintivo que depende do humor
que eu estou no momento mas da
capacidade que eu tenho de compreender o
outro no seu universo como porque ele
pensa assim porque ela pensa assim tem
um com uma construção uma sofrer em cd
em gramas envolvido naquela pessoa que
nem está tão amarrado que ela nem sabe
mais quem ela é
ela é fruto de pensamentos que foi
instruídos de relações desde a infância
que foi colocado em uma tábula rasa e
que jamais o sistema foi tão organizado
não tem mais tempo para pensar nela
porque tantas coisas para fazer fora
dela
esse tem nós já organizamos tem uma
religião que ali você vai entrar em
contato mas o contato é com você
como que alguém pode fazer o contato
conosco mesmo se todos os criadores que
passaram nesse universo que a que chamam
de messi
serys que podem aportar uma outra
dimensão de conhecimento
todos disseram está dentro de você não
está fora
e se formos pensar então deus e
geográfico porque nessa viagem nessas
viagens ao mundo se observou que
dependendo da cultura é uma posição da
crença e todas têm o seu valor na sua
construção
então essa essa posição de cada um vai
construir o seu universo sem crenças sem
peias errando ou acertando acertando e
errando não há esse pecado errar quero
quero deslocar esse universo transcender
desse universo errando porque nele nós
também trazemos resultados às vezes
dolorosos mas pra nós e pra muitos mais
experimentados e e sabendo não é por aí
pelo menos já sei que não é por aí do
que alguém somente dizer e nós temos que
aceitar e que quando erramos vamos ter
uma força em cima de nós dizendo você
não serve porque errou e não tem mais
possibilidade de acertar e aprender é
errar e aprender é acertar e sucesso
depende da instrução que cada um teve
sucesso depende do que cada um construiu
para si então desempregado pode ser um
grande empreendedor um criativo pode ser
um grande homem uma grande mulher de
sucesso
eu desejo que essa tarde pra vocês possa
ser verdadeiramente impactou za porque o
impacto que pode nos fazer pensar de
forma diferente refazer o nosso
pensamento e agradeço ao ted pela essa
oportunidade de trazer a vocês os
estudos ea apresentação desse método
que vocês vão ter oportunidade de
conhecer no site da universidade
meu profundo agradecimento
[Aplausos]